[Música]
como estas a nivel y en el último
proceso la línea recta antes del estreno
qué maravilla que le quien le provoque
estar aquí en montreal con esta
coreografía que creo usted para los
grandes ballets de montreal bueno es una
historia que yo escribí mí misma y
quería escribir la historia de una
familia y de la relación entre la hija y
su papá y me inspiré mucho de la
relación entre málaga y su papá y que
cada vez lo
los periodistas que preguntan pero que
existe para que estuvo
málaga está tan famosa y habilitante y
en su respuesta era que él no hizo nada
pero lo que no hizo él no cortó su ala y
cuando un papá cree en tu hija ella
puede subir muy muy muy lejos de medida
y esto es realmente la historia de
vendetta con familias de magia pero la
hija va a ser el nuevo padrino
y de alguna forma esa relación padre e
hija que están que es tan importante
para la vida de cualquier mujer
finalmente usted se inspiró de mala la
de la activista mala la de la joven
activista mala la para tras transferir
toda esa historia entonces por qué
escoger la madre estaba buscando una
historia que puede no coincidir se
atrapará la atención y el mundo de
vendetta al mundo del padrino es una
película muy famosa y yo no escogí un
tema que es muy conocido muy famoso en
el mundo de la película y ahí me puse mi
propia historia sobre la reacción de una
hija y su papá creo que hay
sus connotaciones al mundo de la
película pero es una nueva historia no
es el padrino famoso pastel número 4 es
realmente una nueva una nueva historia y
también en el mundo de la danza clásica
las historias son muy dulces y muy
romántica y yo quería
escoger un tema que es un poco más duro
un poco más
si estás oscuro pero de manera con humor
con
y con ternura entre las relaciones de la
familia y otra cosa que es particular
que yo encuentro única es que usted
cuenta la historia de la mafia pero a
través de la mirada de una mujer también
lo cual no es muy común porque al
principio bueno el mundo de la violencia
tiene un proyecto poder
la joven un rosal ya carbón descubre el
poder de la violencia y ella no está
contenta con esto pero tiene que
aceptarlo porque es el mundo de su papá
y yendo en la obra se va a desarrollar
como ella entiende este poder y eso y
poder también lógico
ella puede cambiar muchas cosas con el
poder de la violencia pero global
como dije
de otra manera que los hombres hombres o
más
guerrero y ella lo causar con su forma
de pensar
[Música]
criminalidad
esto lo vamos a esperar seguro que sí
anabel lópez ochoa la presentación del
estreno de vendetta es el 24 de mayo con
los gran vale de montreal muchísimas
gracias por esta entrevista la dejó ir
para que para que siga practicando para
que siga dando los últimos detalles y
mucha suerte y vuelva cuando quiera
montreal como yogur o grasa
[Música]